hey 42 here despite the fact that 97% of
people of the common statement that
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day only 44 percent of people
actually eat it on a regular basis the
majority of the global population skips
breakfast but is there any truth to the
old adage is breakfast the most
important meal and what happens to your
body and your mind when you give it a
Miss the word breakfast literally means
to break a fast since you are breaking
your overnight fast it's easy to see why
breakfast is the most commonly skipped a
meal of the day most people have very
little free time in the morning and
would rather catch an extra 15 minutes
of shut-eye before work than stand up in
front of a toaster struggling to keep
their eyes open also your body simply
isn't designed to eat within an hour of
waking up your metabolism is like a fire
you have to stoke it with more wood
every few hours to keep it running
overnight your metabolism mostly shuts
down so when you wake up its confused
and like behind the rest of your body
eating breakfast actually kickstart you
metabolism again and it will continue
running until you go to sleep that night
although it's important to note that
breakfast doesn't speed up your
metabolism as an important difference
but if you don't kick start it with food
it will take between 1 to 2 hours for it
to slowly wake up naturally that's why
you usually don't get the message that
you're pretty darn hungry until a couple
of hours after waking up despite having
last consumed a meal over 9 hours ago
the saying breakfast is the most
important meal of the day has shady
origins it comes from a 1917 edition of
good health magazine in which it says in
many ways to breakfast is the most
important meal of the day the thing is
the magazine was edited by John Harvey
Kellogg the brother of Kellogg's founder
will Keith Kellogg Kellogg's entire
marketing campaign was centered around
promoting breakfast cereals as their
healthiest way to start your day and
most essential food you can consume
furthermore before the 20th century
dedicated breakfast foods didn't even
exist
it's only due to marketing that they do
now pre 20th century for thousands of
years humans usually ate the remains in
whatever was left over from the night
before
Kellogg's bravest claim was that eating
their cereal helps you to lose weight
and that idea has never actually
disappeared from the public
consciousness extravagant weight loss
claims are still used to sell cereals
around the world today so what's the
truth can you really a stone in a
week by eating magical toasted flakes
the largest-ever clinical study on the
relationship between weight loss and
breakfast consumption was carried out in
2014 on 309 participants half of them
were asked to skip breakfast and the
rest to eat it the study concluded that
contrary to widely espoused views this
had no discernible effect on weight loss
in free living adults who are attempting
to lose weight there was absolutely no
difference in weight loss between those
who ate breakfast every morning and
those who skipped it all together there
have been many smaller studies however
the BMJ
took 13 leading randomised trials on
this topic and amalgamated the results
overall they concluded that eating any
kind of breakfast on a daily basis does
not lead to weight loss in fact they
found on average breakfast eaters weight
ever so slightly more than breakfast
skippers but the weight disparity was
not significant enough to throw all your
eggs and cornflakes out of the window
and the trials all ran for a very short
time and didn't pay enough attention to
the type of breakfast that people are
eating none of the studies factored in
whether breakfast eaters a sugary cereal
every morning or whole-wheat toast and
fruit which really dampens the
reliability of the results ultimately
whether or not you should skip breakfast
is a personal choice that will have
different outcomes for different people
depending on your age weight genetics
what time of day you wake up and what
you do after waking skipping breakfast
could be either beneficial or
detrimental to your health and
well-being the general doctor
recommended rule of thumb is really
quite simple if you're hungry eat hunger
is your body's Way of telling you it
needs sustenance so you would be wise
not to ignore it however that's a very
simplistic answer let's take a look at
some science backed pros and cons of
skipping breakfast starting with the
pros we've established that skipping
breakfast every day will not help most
people to lose weight as people tend to
overeat later in the day to compensate
however a team at Cornell University
believes that skipping breakfast only a
couple of times per week could be a
genuinely effective weight-loss strategy
during their studies they found that
people who usually eat breakfast tend
not to overcompensate when they miss it
so if you could get used to the idea of
only eating breakfast say four days per
week then skipping it for three days you
are less likely to gorge on junk food
later in the morning than if you were to
go nuclear and skip breakfast on all
seven days the Cornell team found that
when normal breakfast eaters skipped
breakfast intermittently they ended up
consuming on average four hundred fewer
calories per day on the day's without
any breakfast which is just the right
amount of calorie deficit for safe and
steady weight loss also intermittent
fasting triggers a biological response
called autophagy which is a phase during
which the body clears away any DNA
debris and repairs cellular damage so
skipping breakfast now and then could
help lower the risk of age-related
diseases but what about the cons of
skipping breakfast is it really worth it
well perhaps not before you consider
never eating breakfast ever again
consider the following if you happen to
exert a lot of energy at your job or if
you go to the gym first thing in the
morning not eating breakfast could be a
huge mistake if you skip breakfast
before physical exertion your blood
sugar levels will be at rock-bottom and
you'll have no energy reserves to carry
you through the day if you try to push
yourself on an empty stomach you can
bring on some really nasty side effects
such as dizziness lightheartedness and
nausea
you'll feel lethargic unable to do much
less than if you had eaten because your
focus will be impaired you are
considerably more likely to injure
yourself if for example you're lifting
heavy objects at work or weights in the
gym and if your tank gets too empty
you could end up passing girls but those
of you who work at a desk job aren't
getting off any easier either just like
your muscles your brain needs sustenance
and energy to function if you skip
breakfast your ability to concentrate
and think logically will be impaired a
2005 study tested children over three
weeks some of them ate a healthy oatmeal
based breakfast and some of them ate no
breakfast they were asked to complete a
bunch of cognitive tasks over the three
weeks it concluded that breakfast intake
enhances cognitive performance and boys
and girls showed enhance spatial memory
and girls showed improved short-term
memory after consuming goat meal but if
you are a religious breakfast skipper
poor concentration and low energy levels
could be the least of your worries a
very recent study at the University of
Iowa of over 6,500 Americans concluded
that people who never eat breakfast are
87 percent more likely to die of
cardiovascular disease than breakfast
eaters but there's a large caveat here
it could just be true that people who
eat breakfast tend to take much better
care of themselves in every aspect of
their life research has found that
people who eat breakfast everyday are
less likely to smoke they drink less and
overall they have healthier diets than
breakfast skippers they consume far more
fiber and nutrients in their diet also
eating breakfast presents one more
opportunity each day for an individual
to consume vital fiber and vitamins to
meet their recommended daily amount
which can only have a positive impact on
one's health that is assuming said
breakfast consists of healthy foods
there's obviously a huge difference
between starting your day on a bowl of
muesli and bananas compared to a tire of
pancakes and syrup in summary the idea
that breakfast is some sort of special
meal with magical properties such as
speeding up your metabolism or causing
you to burn more calories throughout the
day are no more than myths many modern
studies have disproved these commonly
espoused fallacies everyone is different
and for some people who may not feel
hungry until 12 o'clock then skipping
breakfast could be beneficial because at
the end of the day breakfast is just
another meal like any other and it's
only purpose is to curb hunger and
intake some healthy proteins fiber and
nutrients so if you're hungry then eat
breakfast if you're not then don't it
really is as simple as that just try to
choose a healthier breakfast if you can
and if you are hell-bent on skipping
breakfast even though you are hungry for
it then the research points to the fact
that the healthiest way to do that is by
intermittent fasting by only skipping
breakfast some days of the week your
body will maintain its usual metabolic
circadian rhythm enabling you to lose
more weight than if you skip it seven
days per week but for me there's another
obvious contour skipping breakfast it
can be damaging to the emotional health
of an individual and relationships in a
world where people are increasingly
interacting with each other less and
less in real life preferring to bury
their heads and smartphones I think for
a family or even a couple to share
breakfast together is truly a crucial
moment each day to develop and maintain
healthy relationships and it can be an
essential
positive tool for the social development
of children as they grow up no matter
how rushed we all are in the modern
world we should all try to make time to
take 30 minutes out of our day and enjoy
some bacon and eggs and who knows you
may feel a whole lot better for doing so
thanks for watching I've just launched
my first book which I encourage funding
for unbound publishing it's called stick
a flag in it a thousand years of bizarre
history from Britain and beyond if you
want to get your hands on a first
edition signed copy then head on over to
unbound the links in the description and
order yours today thank you